Dia de los Muertos uh Miguel Julio
Beauty and Kim joining us along to our
beautiful model we talked a little bit
about the history of the holiday let's
talk about how you get this to stay on
yeah there's a positive of using a wet
to dry cake makeup okay in case you
spray it with we use fix flux from Mac
and you spray it it activates it it gets
wet you paint and then it dries but then
we use a setting spray we spray that all
over that and then you're good and your
lines and everything will stay in place
and it won't crack like we were talking
about right yeah because you don't want
the makeup to crack which I've seen and
certainly you know you want it to stay
okay with that setting spray but the key
you set is wet dry a wet dry makeup
works best if you use a cream-based
makeup
um like Alondra had saying earlier it'll
just like slide off your face by the end
of the night so okay something that has
like a powder base to it and you can get
that at star costume one of our favorite
places to go here in town oh right yeah
they're wonderful they are so good and
you can get that kind of makeup there
good stuff Kim beautiful hair Alondra
thank you guys for waking up early with
us this morning you're on Instagram so
you can check out
um Miguel Julio Beauty everyone happy
Tuesday Dia de los Muertos